I want to talk about when you go in to
meet with a casting director or a
potential agent and when they try to see
you as a certain type or role or
ethnicity yeah any stories from that
that you can share my first guest star
role was last year for Rizzoli and Isles
and I was cast as a Latino guy
Alberto Santana on Rizzoli and Isles I
don't really speak much Spanish but I
can wing it and I know some words and I
made it work but you know I think my
agency in my in my my management and I I
look Latino and I am having an
ambiguously at an ethically ambiguous
look to me and I've come to terms with
that and that's fine but you get in that
room with a direct cast director and
yeah you feel judged they're looking at
your like is he Latino enough I can see
it sometimes in their eyes like is he
Hispanic enough to play this Hispanic
role of Julio or Carlos you know so
there's two sides to that it's great
that I'm getting called in for those
roles because I'll tell you what I have
a better chance at booking Hispanic role
or a multi-ethnic role than a white role
a Caucasian role because guess what the
roles the the the the pool for actors
for just a regular you know five eleven
good-looking Caucasian dude is
ridiculous I can't imagine I you know I
probably getting called it I probably
wouldn't get called in so do I have an
advantage because I have to deal with a
smaller actors pool and compete with
that when that pool
absolutely but there's less lean roles
for for you know multi-ethnic ethnically
ambiguous Hispanic actors right so that
kind of sucks there's a flip side to it
what I'd love to be going out for lead
roles and you know studio films of
course but I don't know if that's you
know it's a business and if you actually
read a great article last week and I
think the percentage of I'm half I'm
part Asian to my mother's Filipino and
it's the the percentage it broke down
the percentage of actors and their
ethnic
these in studio films and I think it was
like Caucasian was like 65 to 70
african-american was like 10% and then
like Hispanic Latino was like five
percent and then Asian was like 3.4
percent and that's scary and kind of
disturbing you know and it and that's a
stat that kind of goes against what I'm
trying to do right you look at that and
you're like that's me so I'm up against
counted the studios and up against the
numbers but then you know an hour later
I was like I'm gonna fight that I'm you
know I'll push there I'll be fine but
it's kind of a scary stat to see that
you know minorities are still not
getting the opportunities that the white
people are getting well when people ask
you what you are maybe they don't yeah
but how do you fight through that
because why don't they just see you as
they want to see you and cast you in
that role right because I mean if you
look at me you might think oh this guy's
Latino when I speak I speak like a you
know like an American kid right what was
your question well I mean do I don't
what do they say to you when you walk in
the room do they say hey are you you
know I mean what what's the constant
where are you from ask where are you
from I'm like oh I'm from New York like
no where are you from I'm like oh well
my background is so-and-so and then they
asked so how's how's the Spanish and I'm
like you know not that strong I'd rather
be like strong too quite strong but it's
not and that definitely hurts me you
know sometimes because they're like well
we know we need someone that speaks
Spanish so that's why my manager is
thinking of buying me rosetta stone have
you ever just flat out said you're
Latino I think that that's what they
want from you and you want them to see
you as that have you ever got a couple
times yeah because that's what they're
looking for so how am I gonna give
myself you know a better chance to get
the job you have to say stuff like that
and it's not completely lying because
filipino actually is derived from
Spanish influence in the Filipino
culture right so I'm not completely
lying sure yeah
what's your advice to other ethnically
ambiguous actors I know there was a
great post on BuzzFeed but it was a
comedy post about what never to ask
someone yeah that's there you're never
sure and they and they did this great
video but a lot of it there was a lot of
truth in it yeah so people like so your
your what are you and then you're just
like you just wait right oh the same
thing yeah I mean but that's a good
thing - they're asking that it is if
they're asking that they're interested
you know and I think that's good for TV
you know you want people be like what is
that girl what is that guy who you know
that's a good thing
at the same time there's a smaller
percentage of actors for multi-ethnic
and you know ethnically ambiguous so
there's a flip side it's good that I'm
competing with a smaller group of actors
but the opportunities are definitely
less I believe it's getting better
there's no doubt it's getting better
and there's always disclaimers on
audition sides and audition pieces at
the end it says NBC is not exclusive is
is always cast from we're diverse we do
not discriminate it says that on all the
audition sides it's like I don't really
because you're looking for a white dude
right now and yeah I go in a lot for a
Latino and um do you not then on your
you know interests oh you know
rollerskating and all this stuff and
then do you put in terms of what your
look is or do you just let them guess
that on their own
my manager told me something and she's
like let them let them worry about it
let them guess you just be you you just
be who you are and they'll they'll
figure it out and if they are trying to
figure a demeans are interested that's
good do you know any that's what he said
leave it to them I actually had half
Filipino half Italian on my IMDB
biography he goes take that down
immediately because I think you said it
because he didn't want me to exclude
myself from Latino so that lets you know
you know they're looking for Latino role
they're like what we can't take him he's
Italian and Filipino that's not what you
know let them judge you
you know which is this business is it's
what it is the casters are looking at
you like not as a person they're looking
at is is he a Latin guy for this role of
Carlos is he just that's the way it is
you know cuz it's a lot of money
involved and they're their marketing
subs to a specific customer they really
are it's just it's just what it is it's
it's it's the evil but it's what you
have to deal with is a professional
actor
you